good afternoon so we'll try and get to
the exams Wednesday esters working on
them so we have one more exam final exam
it is cumulative but it's going to focus
on material from now on and I will give
you review questions that will tell you
basically what will be on it so
everything I asked you on the previous
exam was in the review questions so the
same thing will happen with the final
okay so I will for the earlier lectures
will give you review questions and focus
on what we want you to remember keep up
with the quizzes there will still be a
quiz every week because if you're if the
course is over and you haven't done it
I can't reopen it for you okay so try
and keep up with them there will be one
extra credit opportunity for ten points
so you can add to your grade that way
though that'll be up in about a week or
two okay now today we're going to today
in the next time we're going to talk
about two different patterns of
infection
today is acute and it's actually
appropriate that I'm doing the acute and
dr. Silverstein is doing the persistent
infections because he is persistent and
what is an acute infection did you burn
out my batteries here
no it was the microphone well I can do
it by hand okay this all has to do with
that the pattern of infection that a
virus undergoes so you remember from
what we've talked about already there
are some viruses where if you infect the
cell they will kill the cell the it will
make a lot of viruses we call those
cytopathic viruses it's quite clear
there are also some infections where
there are virus produced but virus but
the cells are not killed nonce the so
called non psychopathic infections and
we talked about how in the host in these
kinds of infections that disease is
largely immuno pathological
there are also some infections I don't
think we've really talked about this
which neither killed the cell nor
produced progeny although you could have
you could view a retrovirus infection as
doing that the retrovirus getting into a
cell integrating and not producing any
variants so these kinds of patterns of
infections lytic or non lytic or the
combination of the two together with
what your host does determines what kind
of infection you're going to have or the
pattern of infection so that's what
we're talking about whether it's a cute
or persistent it's a function of what
the virus does and how the host responds
and here is a graph which I believe you
have already seen which illustrates in a
graph format what we're talking about
here on the top is an acute infection
and the information here in the blue
line is the amount of virus produced
with time so virus production with time
and then the red area is the amount of
disease produced in the host so an acute
infection you have a burst of virus
production accompanied by disease and
then the vite the infection is over it's
a relatively rapid course of events and
typical acute infections are caused by
rhinoviruses common cold viruses
rotaviruses which we will talk about
today and influenza viruses so this is
what we'll talk about today and dr.
Silverstein next time we'll talk about
these various kinds of persistent
infections which basically just go on
for a long period of time and you can
have virus produced for
long time as in here the lymphocytic
Korea meningitis virus eventually
there's disease and death herpes viruses
you have repeated bouts of production of
virus either with or without disease and
then long infections where there's
initially virus and disease produced and
then a smoldering period eventually
leading to death and this is
characteristic of HIV but today we'll
focus on acute infections again these
are relatively brief everything is
relative of course but in terms of a
persistent infection which lasts years
this is much shorter in a healthy host
within days the viruses are eliminated
and usually you get one infection so you
can make vaccines against these viruses
if there are multiple serotypes of
course you can be reinfected depending
on how many serotypes you are and some
viruses utilize this to get around the
immune response so some infections can
be overwhelming I don't want you to get
the idea that these are benign
infections for the most part they can be
life-threatening even in healthy hosts
so influenza which is a acute infection
kills thirty to forty thousand people a
year in the US alone thirty to forty
thousand people and then and so that
always amazes me when people say I don't
need a flu vaccine because they think it
meant you may not be one of those thirty
or forty thousand there are many
zoonotic infections where a virus goes
from an animal into a person that can
also be life-threatening it's an acute
infection it's relatively rapid but
because it's a new virus for the host
they can kill you so here's the course
of a typical acute infection again
you've seen this but where a petition is
wonderful for establishing concepts
it's a Greta graph with time of course
and virus growth you get infected here
the virus begins to multiply you native
DNA defenses of course kick in
immediately and we've talked about those
extensively here if the level of virus
goes above a certain threshold that the
native
fence mechanism can't deal with any
longer than adaptive responses are
induced we talked about the
communication between the innate and
adaptive responses that that caused that
trigger virus keeps replicating
eventually if you are lucky the adaptive
response kicks and of course there's a
10 to 14 day delay before you have a
good adaptive response made virus levels
will decline and eventually the virus is
cleared so there are two outcomes with
an acute infection you clear the
infection or you die that's really it
and so if you're if you're unlucky the
latter occurs and then of course you
have memory your immune response
remembers the pathogen the antigenic
pattern of the pathogen so if you re
infected with a similar virus you will
be protected because the adaptive
response will be much more rapid with
all infections there is what we call an
incubation period that's the initial
period before the symptoms are obvious
and that time viral genomes are
replicating so the virus has entered you
they are replicating and they may or may
not cause symptoms that are obviously
associated with the virus you're of
course responding within hours the
innate system is detected infection you
begin to produce cytokines and remember
those are produced locally but they
diffuse the diffuse all over your body
and they have global effects remember
the fever mallas i don't want to get up
to that it feel lousy aches pains nausea
these are all global effects caused by
an acute virus infection and that's the
initial innate response these are not
typical of any particular virus
infection they're nonspecific symptoms
so you can't really tell what you have
when you have these initial global
effects the incubation period can be
very short or it can be very long and
whether we actually call those virus
infections acute infections where the
incubation period is years is a matter
of debate or not but I'll show you a
chart that that illustrates that in a
moment now short incubation periods
you'll see within the our definition of
acute
and of course like everything else in
science we we apply definitions to try
and categorize things so we can study
them better and so we they're always
examples that span our definitions a
short incubation period it usually means
that the virus infects locally and all
the disease is produced by replication
there so a respiratory virus like flu
replicates in your aspire to re-track
nose where the symptoms are produced so
it's the virus doesn't have to go far to
cause the symptoms so the incubation
period sure pretty straightforward
influenza as an example long incubation
periods I mean that the virus needs to
go somewhere else to cause disease and
it takes time to get there and it may
also be that there are host responses
involved in the disease also so the
incubation period is longer an example
of this is measles so here is a table
with incubation periods of some common
viral infections these are not all acute
infections but I just want to show it to
you to show you the range of incubation
periods from one to two days for
influenza a couple of days for a common
cold these respiratory viruses so again
you see the pattern here the pretty
short incubation periods are those
infections where the symptoms are
produced locally and then you get into
increasing incubation periods
enterovirus as polio virus measles virus
where there's initial entry point in
replication then the virus spreads
somewhere else to cause the actual
disease remember the nonspecific
symptoms of fever and aching that's not
what we're talking about in terms of the
incubation period leading up to those
are actually known as prodromal
syndromes they're not really specific
for any virus the incubation period say
is for polio is 20 days until you get
paralysis not just a fever or muscle
aches so you can see some of them are
quite long and then we move into
persistent long term infections like Hep
B and C the papilloma viruses and AIDS
up to ten year incubation so I wouldn't
consider that to be an acute infection
although you could view it as a acute
infection with a very long incubation
period except that initially when you
are infected with HIV one there is a
burst of virus production and
disease and that it stops and goes on
much longer
gravy's is an acute virus infection that
just takes a long time for the virus to
get from the dog bite to the CNS and the
farther you're away from the CNS that
you are bitten the longer the incubation
period hence 3,200 days so with the
rabies you have time to immunize someone
before the virus enters the CNS there
are also in apparent acute infections
now don't think that every acute
infection gives you symptoms they are
ones that don't give you symptoms they
call those in apparent they are
successful infections though end up in
the viruses terms because they produce
viruses that's what the virus wants to
do with viruses in fact want anything
which we know they don't they need to
produce progeny and whether they produce
disease or not may not matter you make
enough viruses in these in apparent
acute infections to spread but there's
just not enough to make the typical
symptoms of the virus itself you may
have a slight fever or some achiness and
then it goes away because the virus
never gets the endpoint and you may not
think anything of it you'll come to
class and spread the infection to others
or you may not have any symptoms at all
in your shedding infection so these are
in apparent acute infections how do we
know that these occur well there's many
studies have been done in populations
looking at antibodies against specific
viruses and you can see in a population
there is no disease yet there is a rise
in antibody titer which means that these
people have been infected well-adapted
pathogens often follow this pattern a
virus does not have to produce disease
in order to spread of course in some
cases it helps if the virus induces
coughing or sneezing but it isn't
essential so well-adapted pathogens that
don't kill their hosts have this pattern
of in apparent infections so a good
example is not over 90% of polio
infections are in a parent and that's
why this is a tough virus to detect in
the population at least years ago when
it was rampant very hard to detect
because the people most of the people
were infected in shedding and
transmitting to others didn't have a
symptoms so you couldn't put them away
until the virus was gone
so quarantining was actually used for to
try and prevent the spread of polio in
the US but it was absolutely useless
because of this number he had some
people with paralysis which are 1% of
the total infections they're in the
hospital they're quarantined and the
rest of the 99% are walking around with
mild infection spreading the virus yes
is there an evolutionary advantage
that's a good question I'm not sure that
it matters I think it depends on the
virus for for example measles virus
requires a very large population of
susceptible individuals and if it kills
the host then it's not going to be able
to spread effectively so I think it
depends on the virus this is something
we talk about all the time is is it of
any value for a virus to become more
virulent I think not in most cases it
just needs to spread transmissibility is
what is the major factor that really is
selected for it may be that higher
virulence goes along with that
accidentally but I don't think it's
needed so I would guess that these kinds
of in apparent infections are actually
fine and if if we did more sampling of
healthy populations I think we would
find that there are a lot of in apparent
infections we don't know about I think
in the animal of kingdon and the animals
out in the wild nonhumans I suspect
there are many many unknown virus
infections and that the animals are fine
it's a perfect example of adaptation to
this kind of lifestyle
now acute infections are common public
health problems for a number of reasons
and they are most frequently associated
with serious epidemics most frequently
of course aids also infects millions of
people but that's one virus and but the
intent in general the acute infections
are those historically that have been
associated with outbreaks polio
influenza measles that occur each year
smallpox of course before it was
eradicated they are often associated
with viruses that go from animals to
humans
he's again we call zoonotic infections
Ebola viruses there is a zoonotic
infection going from a bat to a human
and there are many other examples of
that as well
so these infections are hard to deal
with in terms of Public Health so people
who deal with human health physicians
epidemiologists drug companies public
health officials because by the time you
feel ill or make a an immune response
most acute infections are over so if you
remember the curve the graph we showed
of the immune response versus virus the
virus Peaks and then the immune response
is really kicking in and really the
infection is over for the most part so
you feel ill it's really kind of late to
do anything about it if you have an
acute infection with with a few
exceptions virus has already spread on
so you can't stop it you're shedding
virus in the early days and you're
spreading it on to the next so so it's
really a good adaptation evolutionarily
that's what these viruses have adapted
to do replicate very quickly early on in
the absence of symptoms they're hard to
diagnose and in large populations in
crowded situations extremely difficult
to control and that's why certain in
certain countries people wear face masks
all the time we don't do that here in
the US but I'm sure you've seen
photographs of other countries people
wearing face masks to try and get around
this issue
and as this as the world has aged and in
the population has increased we have
increased the number of crowding
situations that foster virus spread like
daycare centers it was a time where
there were no daycare centers right
mother stayed home and took care of the
kids but now we have daycare centers
where all the kids exchange their virus
infections and then they bring them home
to their parents and I can tell you I
have first-hand experience at that it
happens all the time up until a certain
age military boot camps this has been
around for a long time and it's is
historically a good way to spread
infection college dorms nursing homes
schools and offices increasingly crowded
great ways to spread acute infections
and often you can see very explosive
spread of particular infection
under these conditions you could if you
read the infectious disease literature
you will see at a regular basis for
example outbreaks of gastroenteritis and
daycare centers nursing homes colleges
always happens in explosive outbreaks
because the virus is being spread before
there are obvious symptoms very
difficult to control so this is as an
implication for antiviral drugs when
they are available they have to be used
early an infection so for an acute
infection if you want to treat these
with antivirals you have to catch the
infection before symptoms are manifested
by the time this is symptoms arise it's
really almost too late now persistent
virus infections don't have this
limitation my if AIDS is incue is is
incubating for ten years you have a lot
of time to interrupt with antivirals
hepatitis C also but acute infections
that are very short this is an issue an
example of this is Tamiflu the inhibitor
of influenza virus you have to take this
within 48 hours of getting sick
otherwise it's of no value whatsoever so
you've you're faced with a conundrum
because most people when they first feel
ill with flu are you gonna rush to a
clinic or a physician and and then get
diagnosed there are rapid diagnosis kits
but the efficiency of those is pretty
poor and then maybe the physician will
say well that may be influenza because
it's going around here here's some
Tamiflu so that's the scenario most of
us stay home and then after two days
it's too late to take Tamiflu so how do
we defend against acute infections a
primary natural defense of courses our
innate response which is very important
the adaptive response doesn't kick in
for at least a couple of days of course
adaptive ReCellular responses in
particular are very important for
resolving these infections but the
antibody responses for the most part
don't do anything the adaptive response
clears your virus and provides memory
now what would happen if you had a
strong innate defense but no adaptive
defense they could to you can actually
do this experimentally in animals and
the answer is that without innate
defenses the infection can spread from
the primary site of in fact
so this being a response of course is
central in controlling the infection and
if it can't control it the the adaptive
response has to kick in
and people without immune responses
immunocompromised individuals they may
not have either B cells or T cells where
they may not have either infections
acute infections in particular can be
disastrous now the memory aspect of
acute infections is important
acute infections are typically usually
one-time-only infections and therefore
we can make vaccines against the agents
to provide protection and in fact we
learned that vaccines could work many
years ago from memory and people people
who had an infection didn't get
reinfected again Edward Jenner noticed
this in terms of smallpox and we'll talk
about that in the vaccine lecture but
there are always exceptions and
antigenic variation can bypass adaptive
immune defenses so by antigenic
variation we mean for example influenza
virus undergoes a yearly antigenic
variation so if you get a vaccine this
year against the currently circulating
strains by a year or two from now the
strain will have varied sufficiently so
that the the memory that you have isn't
enough to prevent infection yeah well
remember all viruses make mistakes in
their in replicating a nucleic acid the
RNA viruses can't correct the mistake so
they have a very high error rate so all
RNA viruses make a lot of mistakes and
some can't accommodate those changes in
their proteins so influenza virus for
reasons we don't understand the
glycoproteins on the surface can undergo
enormous changes they're all localized
at near the receptor binding portion and
it can kind of accommodate those other
viruses can't they don't do a measles
virus hardly varies at all they're
structural constraints so it's only
answer I can give you we don't
understand the basis for that but some
viruses are better at accommodate
than others now I don't think the
vaccine really pushes it because not
enough people are where ever immunized
in any one year to make a difference
probably it's just that the population
immunity pushes the virus to mutate or
selects for viruses that escape the
immunity
the alternative is Rhino virus it
doesn't undergo variation but there are
hundreds more than a hundred different
serotypes circulating at the same time
and so every and any given year you're
likely to get another common cold yeah
for flu I don't know offhand but that's
different for every virus right I don't
know what the number is for flu at the
moment to say a hundred percent so they
get vaccinated okay so we're going to
talk about some specific examples of
acute infections I picked these five
because they're transmitted in slightly
different ways and just so you can learn
about how acute infections develop how
they're transmitted in some of the
details dealing with them so the first
one we'll talk about is influenza virus
and here is an influenza virion at the
upper right if you remember it is an
envelope with viruses virus the RNAs are
negative stranded and they're present in
segments so these viruses can go in to
go reassortment which is another way to
have genetic variation there are three
types of influenza they're called
influenza A B and C the a and b f--
influenza strains cause a very similar
respiratory disease influenza C virus is
mostly in apparent infections so there
are a lot of there's a lot of
transmission of influenza C that we've
learned about through serous surveys but
very little disease associated with it
so we don't immunize against influenza C
because it doesn't really cause
significant disease we do immunize
against a and B influenza A strains
cause pandemics these are the outbreaks
the global epidemics large outbreaks of
influenza every X number of years 2030
years we just had a pandemic in 2009
does anyone know when the previous
pandemic was before 2009 of influenza
sooner than that it was the year that
Richard Nixon was elected president the
first time I might be wrong on that
anybody know that year 68 was he elected
in 68 but doesn't matter it was 1968 so
that was a long period that was a long
period between 68 and 2009 the further
the one before 68 was 57 so that was
much shorter and then before 57 was 1918
so again much longer so it's not
terribly regular but every so many years
there is a pandemic and that only
happens with influenza A virus this
virus the hallmark of this is antigenic
variation every year or two the virus
changes enough to evade your immunity
and every X number of years it changes
substantially so you have a big outbreak
yes it's probably a number of factors so
when when say let's say we have a strain
of influenza circulating for ten or
twenty years it changes a little bit
every few years but there's still a
large population immunity against it and
then if another strain is introduced
into the population which in a
population has no immunity against it
that will cause a pandemic so it's
dependent on the introduction of a new
strain probably from an animal vector so
2009 we believe that a new strain came
from pigs and it reasserted in pigs and
then it got into people and because
there was no immunity and also had the
ability to transmit effectively in
people it caused the pandemic so pigs we
have created this reservoir because
these pigs are the pig industry that we
grow up and they happen to be very
susceptible to various strains of
influenza they get infected by their
handlers they get infected by birds that
fly overhead and drop on them
influenza viruses so they could they
turn out to be a very good mixing vessel
so influenza viruses are respiratory
pathogens they enter your respiratory
tract by inhaling remember aerosols
containing virus that you inhale someone
else has produced that by coughing or
sneezing or talking or you may touch at
a contaminated surface and put you the
virus into your nose it was a very
interesting study done a couple of many
about five or six years ago they said
Swiss biologist he took bank notes in
Switzerland and they brought him into
the lab and cut them up and looked for
influenza virus on them and actually
what they did is they put virus on the
banknotes and then they saw how long it
lasted and they found that it could last
over a week on the banknotes so you know
people are going in there and taking
their money out and they're rubbing
their nose and put on the money someone
else could get and in fact they found
that if there's mucus with the virus it
lasts even longer it protects it so you
can get it by contact not just by
aerosol yeah only in Switzerland yeah
who else would you do that study right
so the virus enters your upper tract it
can multiply there and cause a variety
these upper tract clinical
manifestations rhinitis pharyngitis
laryngitis but influenza is very
characteristically able to go down the
track it moves down the respiratory
epithelium all the way down into the
trachea and that's why when you get flu
you really feel this infection in your
chest you could absolutely distinguish
it from an upper tract infection in the
most serious cases it gets down into
your alveoli and causes pneumonia
essentially and it can be a big problem
so you can see here influenza virus can
cause
tracheitis bronchitis bronchiolitis and
bronchopneumonia all the way down into
the alveoli so it can go up and down the
entire tract uncomplicated influenza the
incubation period is short one to five
days and depending on how much virus you
in hit you ingest or inhale and how good
your immune system is all of our immune
systems are different you can pinpoint
to the moment the time you get flu you
can absolutely say uh right
an hour ago I started feeling lousy you
get a headache chills dry cough I mean
in retrospect you pinpoint it because
when you get this it could just be the
virology exam that's causing the
headache but then as the symptoms
increase you say oh that's when it began
it's followed by a high fever muscle
aches laziness anorexia and you have a
peak of fever within 24 hours quite high
fever and then it begins to go down
after a couple of days so your fever
goes down it's gone by day six when the
fever goes down you think I'm getting
better but no virus isn't done with you
yet these symptoms by the way bless you
of these symptoms can differ and yet
very young kids or old people because
they have very different immune systems
as the fever declines then you start to
cough and sneeze more respiratory
symptoms you go to a productive cough
which means you have a lot of mucus it
goes from being dry to the hacking
productive mucusy wet cough and this can
go on for one to two weeks and during
that time the virus is replicating
throughout your tract and this depends
on the receptors human influenza strains
can replicate throughout the entire
human tract because the receptors for
those are in the upper and lower tract
if you happen to be infected by an avian
influenza virus strain they only like
certain receptors which are present in
your lower tract as well how do you
diagnose it it's very difficult because
it's a quick infection but we do try and
diagnose it because we have antivirals
and we'd like to use this especially in
people who are at risk that's why I said
before if you say you have a nursing
home and you have evidence that there's
an outbreak of influenza just treat
everybody with with antivirals you don't
even waste time because it's a very
at-risk population so influenza causes
what's known as ili and influenza like
illness very hard to clinically
differentiate from other virus
infections high fever these are the
criteria though high fever cough or sore
throat that's it so the CDC definition
of influenza like illness high fever
cough or sore throat if you have that
they say you should get Tamiflu
yeah of course there shouldn't be any
other known cause of illness now this
here's rapid lab tests what role do they
have there are some tests that can be
done in the doctor's office which just
involve taking some respiratory
secretion and putting it on a stick of
some kind which looks for viral antigen
it develops very quickly they have about
a 50% success rate so they'll say no you
don't have flu when you do have flu half
the time so they have really poor
accuracy the best test of course are PCR
based tests but if you go to a doctor's
office and you're coughing and hacking
and the physician is just going to
prescribed Tamiflu especially if it's
flu season and you're not going to be
doing a PCR test PCR test will be done
to study spread of the infection in a
population but on a regular basis not
likely so here are some graphs that show
you symptoms versus virus shedding and
immune responses let's start in the
upper left here this is actually a an
experiment that was done in volunteers
you can infect volunteers with influenza
virus strains you have to use strains
that don't kill you of course very very
mild strains and then you can measure
symptoms and secretions so that's what
they've done in this experiment
inoculate these individuals and put the
pipette virus into their noses and then
they at different times after infection
they look at virus shedding which is the
dark circles here and the symptom score
so you have to make a qualitative
judgment coughing amount of mucus for
some of these they actually make you
blow your nose and they way the tissues
and they express it in grams of snot as
we use the car so here you see that
there's not a big difference in the
amount of virus for when the virus
production occurs and the onset of
symptoms you see a day one here there's
already shedding and there is already
some symptoms and they both go up pretty
much in parallel so that's good because
as soon as you have symptoms it it means
you're starting to shed virions but not
before that
so for flu that's a good thing it's not
the case with all acute virus infections
here we're looking at virus production
compared with interferon in the
dashed lines and then various antibodies
in the nasal wash and in the serum so
you can see the virus peaks at about two
or three days in this experiment goes
down rapidly and look at the antibodies
or rays are coming up way after the
virus is already gone
so the EMA in this case and influenza
the antibody is not playing a major role
in clearance all this virus is cleared
by the cellular response pretty much and
then of course you do have memory which
will help let next time you get infected
now influence is a seasonal infection in
in our climate we have a temperate
climate here it happens in the winter
and you can see it by this graph which
is looking at influenza of different
types a and B and different subtypes
which we haven't talked about but there
also a and B AAS are classified into
different subtypes as are B's so you can
see there's a peak here in the winter
months every year 2004-2005 5 6 6 7 and
7 a very reproducible very little
activity in in between this is just a
number of samples that are positive for
influenza here you can see here 3,000
peak here and these are done by CDC
collaborating labs and then there's
subtypes as well so it's a seasonal
infection in temperate climates and
other climates it it also displays some
seasonality but happens at different
times of the year now what causes the
symptoms of flu and the tissue damage
well the virus replication does the
virus is cytopathic and it kills cells
but there's also good evidence that the
immune response plays a big role in
these in the lung pathology these are
sections from lungs of mice that were
infected with influenza virus and here's
a normal lung you can tell it looks very
nice there lots of air air pack play
airway here ways are there are no
infiltrating immune cells this is a
mouse infected with influenza virus
these dark cells are all immune cells
that are infiltrating into the infected
area they're trying to clear the
infection but in fact they also damage
cells because some of these are
cytotoxic t-lymphocytes
trying to kill infected cells and in
your lung that will cause lung pathology
the bottom two panels they've treated
these mice with a particular drug that
inhibits certain cytokines that are
produced by these lymphocytes and you
can see with this one number four
there's markedly less interest rate in
this mouse lung so you can't get rid of
it entirely but you can reduce the
infiltrate in these in these mice the
infection is less lethal so you dampen
the cellular immune response you
decrease the lethality so there's some
evidence that in fact the pathology is
immune based so it could be that at some
point in the future in certain at-risk
populations we might be using such
inhibitors to prevent serious lung
disease in influenza you get some
complications besides the primary
infection you can get primary viral
pneumonia as I said the virus can go all
the way down into the alveoli and that's
quite serious you can also get secondary
bacterial amount pneumonia after the
first infection of influenza has
occurred then the bacteria move in and
you get a bacterial pneumonia
generalized muscle pain known as
Myositis sometimes hard involvement
virus is not replicating there but
there's a second some secondary
consequences of infection perhaps having
to do with respiratory difficulty
pressure in the pulmonary trunk and so
forth and a syndrome called Reye's
syndrome which is an involvement of the
liver and the central nervous system
again there's no virus replicating at
those sites but there is pathology
associated there and we don't really
understand how the virus triggers it
what do you do about influenza you go to
the drug store you can buy all the
over-the-counter stuff that may or may
not make you feel better or you can get
prescription antivirals there are three
Tamiflu and Relenza those are the trade
names these are the chemical names these
are inhibitors of the neuraminidase
which is one of the two glycoproteins on
the surface of the virus particle and we
will talk about how they work in the
antiviral lecture and then there's an
older drug called romantic which is an
inhibitor of the ion channel that's in
the membrane of the virus
and we'll talk about that mechanism as
well of course there's always a vaccine
and we always tell people to get it
every year but the rate of vaccination
in this country is not very good and
hence there's always influenza every
year okay that's flu let's go to polio
now this is a virus transmitted by a
very different route and it's a very
different virus it is a non envelope
virus it has a shell an icosahedral
shell made up of four different proteins
it's rather small 30 nanometers in
diameter that's an electron micrograph
of the particles the structure of this
virus was solved many years ago by x-ray
crystallography and this is the kind of
picture you can make when you have the
coordinates of every atom in the virus
particle so you can build models like
this and see what they look like so the
the capsid of course made up of four
different proteins VP once before
repeated with icosahedral symmetry
giving you all those nice axes of
symmetry like that fivefold axis of
symmetry right there the capsid of
course exists to protect the viral RNA
which is inside it these are plus
stranded RNA viruses pathogenesis of
polio you ingest it you get if you
acquire infection by fecal contamination
because the virus is passed in the feces
so a new host acquires it by
contamination you ingest that it goes
down into your intestinal tract it
infects the mucosa of the intestine
passes through the basement membrane
causes inflammation of the mucosa passes
through to the lymph system and then on
to the blood and it causes a very MIA
from the blood the virus can get into
the CNS and it does so very infrequently
but when it does it causes polio
myelitis we think it gets there either
by direct penetration from capillaries
in the CNS or maybe by axonal transport
so muscles of course are vascularized
they carry the virus to the muscle and
virus can get into the end plate of
nerve of nerves in the muscle and can be
carried up into the spinal cord by
axonal transport and once they're in the
spinal cord the virus replicates in
motor neurons no other cell type
in the spinal cord it kills them
probably by lysis this is a little virus
and then if you have enough neurons
destroyed you get paralyzed this is a
mouse that we made susceptible to polio
many years ago now polio is a uniquely
human infection in nature it only
infects people nobody else and in fact
in the lab you can infect other animals
you can infect certain kinds of
non-human primates but no other animal
mice for example cannot be infected
because they don't have a receptor for
the virus but a number of years ago one
of my students cloned the gene encoding
the receptor for polio that's shown here
it's a transmembrane protein and then
another student took the gene for that
protein and made a transgenic Mouse and
if you then take these transgenic mice
they're now expressing poliovirus
receptor from humans and infect them
with polio they develop polio myelitis
so the receptor is the only thing
between poliovirus being able to
replicate in a mouse so that's nice
because it gave us a nice model to study
the pathogenesis of the disease rather
than having to use larger much larger
animals and so you can do experiments
like this where you infect the mouse
with poliovirus and then when the mouse
gets paralyzed you take the spinal cord
out and you do sections and you ask
where is the virus replicating so here
this is a mouse that had been paralyzed
when this section was taken you can see
all of these immune cells infiltrating
into the area they've come into the
spinal cord to try and clear the
infection they're brought there by
cytokines that are produced by the
infected cells so lots of sales of we
don't know what these are we never
actually looked but they're probably
lymphocytes and macrophages of various
sorts and then the green dots are where
the virus is replicating we hybridize
this section with a RNA probe that would
detect virus RNA and these are neurons
you can tell they're large cells they're
triangular shaped pyramidal shape and
those are the neurons that the virus is
replicating in and again if you destroy
enough neurons that are innovating a
particular muscle the muscle becomes
paralyzed so that's the basis of the
parallel
disease so here is a nice depiction of
the time course of polio this is taken
from a text book it from the 1950s so
medical textbooks don't have polio in
them anymore because we don't have it in
this country but in the 50s there was
plenty of polio so every textbook of
medicine had chapters on polio myelitis
so this is a handwritten hand-drawn
figure from that time and what we're
looking at here is a time course of
polio and various things that are going
on so here's the time up here the
different phases of infection we're
looking at temperature here so you can
see so here's exposure to the virus
after about a seven day incubation
period we have a spike of temperature
headache sore throat nausea nonspecific
symptoms of a virus infection caused by
cytokine production most of the people
get well and they go on and they're fine
but 1% of those individuals the virus
then remains in them that you get
another spike in temperature accompanied
by stiffness pain and paralysis between
day ten and fifteen so one percent of
infection as a result in invasion of the
CNS and you get the paralytic disease
and look at the virus production so
here's virus and the feces so that it
peaks at about the first time of
temperature here a day after day seven
and then it continues for a long period
of time so you excrete virus in the
feces for over a month whether you have
paralysis or not so that's how you
spread the virus to others
here is another graph of virus in the
blood and antibody just to show you that
here's the initial peak of virus that
cord sides with that first bout of
nonspecific symptoms and then it goes
down on its own and the antibody comes
up much later so that is the antibody is
not responsible for clearing that virus
and then virus in the central nervous
system is shown on the bottom just after
day ten virus goes up in the CNS and it
Peaks at the time of paralysis so this
only happens in individuals who have
paralytic symptoms yeah
now these are these are people who add
polio in the 50s you had thousands of
people with polio in the u.s. so you
could take specimens you don't give them
polio but they got infected and you
could take serum and you could take CSF
to look for virus in the CNS so all
these things you can sample feces serum
you take the temperature so these are
natural infections you can't do this
anymore because we don't have it yes so
sometimes in family situations when one
child had polio you could roughly
estimate when the others were infected
because they would they would be brought
in to the hospital sometime later and
you could do a history and find out when
the other child was infected so a nice
summary of all of the whole time course
of polio the pathogenesis as I said
humans are the only known reservoir it's
spread by fecal oral transmission it's
also a seasonal infection in temperate
climates it Peaks during the warm months
we're not sure why that probably has to
do with children being outside and
playing with one another during this
time there is a complication if you have
paralytic polio you may get something
called post-polio syndrome which happens
30 or 40 years after the original the
initial paralysis and I should say that
many individuals can be rehabilitated
from having polio paralysis you can have
your limb function restored by therapy
sometimes the virus does replicate in
respiratory control centers and you have
respiratory failure that that would get
you in an iron lung but even then you
can eventually come out of it
so not a high fatality rate but a lot of
these individuals who were having normal
lives 30 to 40 years later would get
paralyzed again so that's called
post-polio syndrome about 25 to 40
percent of the original paralytic cases
this occurred in doesn't seem to be any
virus present in these individuals we're
not sure what's happening one
the theories is that normally as you age
you lose so many neurons at a certain
rate and if you've lost many to polio
then you have fewer backup neurons so
that as you age you you accrue another
paralysis but that's a theory there's
really no proof for it of course now
that there's no polio in the US there's
less and less post-polio syndrome in the
u.s. hi this is the what has happened
with polio in the u.s. from 1950 to 2007
between 15 and 20 thousand cases a year
these are paralytic cases so I remember
fifteen to twenty thousand paralytic
cases the the paralytic rate is one in a
hundred so there are many more
infections going on here the inactivated
polio vaccine was introduced in 1952 and
it eliminated most of the disease in the
u.s. the live infectious vaccine in 1962
and the last case of polio in the u.s.
1979 indigenous meeting caused by a wild
type virus and we'll talk about this
more in the vaccines lecture but right
now there's no more polio it's
considered eradicated from the US and
many other countries as well next virus
is measles virus this is a paramyxovirus
it is one of the most contagious human
viruses highly infectious it before
vaccine 40 million infections per year
250,000 deaths per year mostly in
children and it requires a substantial
population for transmission between 300
and 500,000 individuals so small pop
small isolated populations don't have
measles because they can't sustain the
transmission of the virus the virus is
an envelope RNA virus that the genome is
negative stranded RNA it's in at present
in a helical configuration wrapped up in
a variety of different proteins
including of course the RNA polymerase
this is a negative strand virus so it
has to bring in a polymerase with it
there is an envelope around the genome
and it's and in the envelope are the
glycoproteins the hemagglutinin in the
fusion protein which are involved in
attachment
in fusion here's an electron micrograph
of the particles they are larger than
polio and influenza viruses slightly
large viruses pathogenesis there is one
sera type of measles virus and as I said
there's really very little antigenic
variation so once you get infected
you're pretty much protected for life
it's transmitted by respiratory
secretions
so you sneeze or cough you exhale virus
containing the virus and droplets and
you infect others here now we have a
different situation from polio there is
a period of shedding of virus two to
three days before the rash occurs so
when measles was rampant in the u.s. it
was quite clear when kids had measles
because they were covered with a rash
but before that they were shedding virus
and that's why it spread so effectively
in schools and other settings because
the children weren't weren't kept at
home nearly all infected individuals
show signs of disease again very
different from polio that only 1% got
paralytic disease here almost a hundred
percent of people infected with measles
will show the rash disease pathogenesis
you inhaled the virus in a aerosol it
multiplies in your respiratory
epithelium and then enters the
bloodstream so it's not like influenza
where it remains in the respiratory
tract this virus enters the bloodstream
and then spreads to other organs so it
has a longer incubation period as a
consequence there is then a secondary
viremia remember the virus multiplies in
these organs initially then there's a
secondary viremia and that brings virus
to the skin where it causes a rash and
the rash is a delayed type
hypersensitivity reaction it is a virus
multiplying in cells and T cells coming
in to try and clear the infection they
make the rash
there are also rare complications of
measles that we'll talk briefly about it
can enter your brain and cause
encephalitis or it can cause a very
interesting disease subacute sclerosing
pan encephalitis SS PE and this is
something that happens
many years after you get measles so a
child will get measles they recover
they're fine 30 years later they start
to have this new progressive
neurodegeneration
they eventually die it's a hundred
percent fatal and it's caused by the
initial measles infection so here's a
timeline of some of these events you
have infection here there's a primary
very Mia the virus spreads to other
tissues so that's the incubation period
then there's what we call a prodromal
period which happens just which is the
period just before the rash so the rash
is occurring at around day 14 so it's a
two-week incubation period and you can
see that that's plenty of time for these
kids to shed virus and pass it on to
other people at the onset of rash you
have antibody produced and eventually
recovery so uncomplicated measles is
associated with a high fever cough and
symptoms of a cold runny nose
conjunctivitis and cop lick spots these
are white spots in the mouth which are
shown on the bottom here I'm not sure
you'll be able to see this but in the
day when measles was rampant this was
diagnostic for measles if the kid had
these white spots that right down here
tiny white spots on the mucosa inside
the cheek was pretty much clear that was
measles the rash is all over the body
face extremities trunk so this is the
delayed type hypersensitivity rash
caused by virus infection
this virus too has complications
encephalitis as I said the virus can get
into your CNS one in 3,000 cases so
3,000 cases of measles one of those
encephalitis sspe many years later and
then as we talked about a few lectures
ago this virus causes immunosuppression
so as a consequence you don't having a
good immune response against other
pathogens that you might encounter so
you get secondary infections as a
consequence of having measles and that's
the main cause of death in third-world
children who get measles they get
immunosuppressed and they get other
infant
parasites or bacteria so how do you
prevent measles well in the US before a
vaccine there were three to four million
cases a year four to five hundred deaths
and forty eight thousand
hospitalizations and interestingly or
importantly a thousand cases of chronic
disability caused by encephalitis the
virus multiplying in your brain so
viruses in your brain is not a good
thing they can wreak havoc and one of
them is is this we stop transmission of
measles in the u.s. by 2000 by using the
vaccine that is endemic transmission
they're still populations in the u.s.
who refuse to be vaccinated so there are
outbreaks of measles all over as a
consequence so right now the vaccine we
use is composed of three different
viruses measles along with mumps and
rubella viruses MMR back in 1998 some of
you may remember a British
gastroenterologist named Andrew
Wakefield claimed that the MMR vaccine
caused autism this study has since been
refuted over and over but still parents
refused to immunize their kids because
of this and there are always outbreaks
of measles there have been quite a few
in the UK and Ireland and then people
traveling bring them to the US and they
cause outbreaks here in the US and under
under immunized populations so we don't
have measles circulating but it can be
brought in from Europe where there are
large outbreaks so here's a graph
showing you the impact of the vaccine
here cases of measles per year in the
u.s. six hundred eight hundred thousand
the vaccine licensed in the 60s and you
can see it eliminated measles now we
don't have anymore circulation of
measles virus so this is measles disease
and this is measles induced death so the
vaccine is quite effective okay the next
virus the next acute infection
gastroenteritis so in 24 hours anywhere
in the world about 200 million people
have gastroenteritis gastroenteritis is
is an inflow
of the intestinal tract accompanied by
diarrhea and the amount of diarrhea
these individuals pass these 200 million
people equals the volume of water
falling over Victoria Falls in one
minute that is a lot of water 65 million
liters per minute of diarrhea so most of
that is viral in fact and a big cause is
rotavirus the single most important
cause of diarrhea illness in infants and
children worldwide it counts for 30 to
50 percent of all severe diarrheal
disease in that age group these viruses
were just discovered in the 1970s we
didn't know what was causing
gastroenteritis we thought it was mainly
bacteria and certainly some bacteria do
cause gastroenteritis but someone at the
NIH was looking at mucosal biopsies from
kids with gastroenteritis and he saw a
virus particles than those were
rotaviruses it turns out there are seven
different cero groups of these viruses
so you have to keep that in
consideration when you make a vaccine
because they're all circulating in
different places they infect many
different animals besides us these
viruses are like real viruses they have
a segmented double-stranded RNA genome
which means they can readily Rhea sort
so rotavirus is infect everybody you are
all seropositive for rotavirus I'm sure
unless you're living in a cave for all
your life the infections are also
seasonal they peak in the wintertime and
as I said that the most common cause of
childhood gastroenteritis 25 million
physician visits per year 2 million
hospitalizations 800,000 deaths so this
is a significant pathogen now in the
u.s. before we introduce the vaccine
every child was infected by five years
of age and in one of one in 72 of those
children were hospitalized and in the
developing world in the u.s. this can be
handled although it was fatal in cases
where you couldn't hydrate the child
quickly enough so the key to saving an
infant that has viral gastroenteritis to
make sure you give them fluids and
many countries in the developing world
they can't do this and so the children
die so it accounts for 5% of all the
mortality in children less than five
years old and this is the global
distribution of rotavirus deaths just
recently you see there's no more in in
the developed countries in the US just
very little in Europe Russia Australia
but Asia Africa in even South America
each dot i think is 500 deaths so you
can see there's a huge burden of infant
mortality caused by this and it's really
mainly because they cannot get these
infants intravenous fluids rapidly
enough so this is what the virus looks
like it's a typical real virus it has an
icosahedral shell in fact it has two of
them it has two icosahedral shells one
inside and one outside and they are
viral glycoproteins in this shell
they're called vp4 and then the shell
itself is vp7 and i point that out
because those are two of the more
important proteins to make antibodies
against if you want to be protected
against these viruses inside is the
double-stranded RNA genome when these
viruses were first seen in those
biopsies of intestinal mucosa this is
what they looked like and the guy who
discovered them said oh they look like
little wheels and that's why he called
them rotaviruses so you can see here
they very symmetrical pathogenesis it's
transmitted by fecal oral contamination
you shed the virus and your feces and
someone else picks it up you don't need
very much virus to infect you ten virus
particles are enough to cause
gastroenteritis and as I said young
infants are at risk for dehydration you
do get infected over and over again as
you age but the subsequent infections
are milder and eventually you don't get
disease because you have antibodies that
build up against these viruses now you
can be infected and you can shed virus
even though you don't have symptoms and
so you become a carrier of rotavirus and
that's one of the main ways that it's
spread in in larger situations you've
shed a lot of virus in the feces ten to
the eighth to ten to the
tenth particles per milliliter so just
think of all that 65 million gallons is
that liters per minute and multiply it
times ten to the eighth to ten to the
tenth particles lot of virus there how
do you get it contaminated hands and
foods you have a food handler who has an
infection with no symptoms if he or she
had symptoms they should stay home but
they have no symptoms they're shedding
virus because they've had many
infections over the years so it's
asymptomatic and they have virus on
their hands and they contaminate the
food you know all the signs and the
restrooms employees restrooms of
restaurants employees must wash their
hands the motivation was in part
rotavirus there are other viruses that
cause gastroenteritis as well because we
know a lot of these individuals are
asymptomatic shedders and so if they
wash their hands you can really cut down
on the burden of infection these viruses
are also quite stable so they will last
on environmental surfaces and that's
another way you can pick them up the
disease is self-limiting vomiting watery
diarrhea low-grade fever wonderful
infection to have as I said asymptomatic
infections are important three one two
three day incubation period then
vomiting followed by four to eight days
of diarrhea sound good but then you get
better
for the most part recovery is usually
complete unless you don't take fluids I
got an email last week from someone she
said my husband is vomiting as diarrhea
and he doesn't know what to do she said
I think he has that roto virus and I
said he might but just have him drink a
lot of water
she said should I go to the doctor I
said no there's nothing to do there's no
antiviral they just have to drink a lot
of water and you'll be fine so how does
it work you ingest contaminated food or
water the virus goes into your
intestinal tract and multiplies in the
mucosal surfaces there and you can see
this is a section of intestinal villi
and these dark spots are where the virus
is multiplying and that causes a fluid
imbalance in fact a couple of lectures
ago we talked about how this is one of
those viruses that makes a toxin it
makes a toxin it
a protein called VP 4 and VP 4 probably
causes the diarrhea so here's a
rotavirus binding to intestinal
epithelial cells the things I want to
point out here are that the infected
cells produce cytokines that attract T
cells and of course those cause
intestinal cell damage as they try to
eliminate the infection in this cell
here you can see NS P 4 is being
produced that's the toxin produced by
the virus it causes a excretion of
chloride and that leads to a fluid
imbalance giving you diarrhea there's
also some evidence that the virus
interacts in some way with the enteric
nervous system so this question mark
here might be the virus protein at SP 4
it could be that NS p 4 interacting with
this nervous system it also has a role
in in diarrhea as well now there is
there are a couple of vaccines against
rotavirus because there's significant
pathogens the first one was called rota
shield and it was a reassortant between
human and bovine sorry rhesus monkey
rotaviruses was licensed in 1998 so they
start with a rhesus rotavirus and these
viruses don't cause disease in people so
you make reassortant of those rhesus
viruses with human viruses and so you
then select for viruses that have the
human glycoproteins on the surface of
the particle and all the other genes are
from the rhesus rotavirus so those
viruses you can ingest they will make
antibodies against the human viral
proteins but you don't get sick okay
and these are just some of the
reassortant that are used unfortunately
this was suspended a year after use
because there was some evidence that
this vaccine was causing in kids so you
give it to very young kids it was
causing intussusception so
intussusception is when your small
intestine Telescope's into the colon
alright so it's a natural complication
of a rotavirus infection and there was
some statistical evidence that it was
increasing in these individuals getting
this vaccine so they pulled it off the
market it's not clear that in fact the
vaccine was at fault here at all it's a
big debate going on about this in fact
this
vaccine is being retested in other areas
of the world so right now we then the
number of years later two other vaccines
were licensed and we're using these now
one of them is called roto tech it's a
reassortment reassortant between human
and bovine strains same logic as the
rhesus human resource from the previous
vaccine so that's the rota Tech right
here there are one two three four five
different reassortant and this is so you
cover all the different important sera
groups and then there's another one
called Roderick's
this is actually a human isolate that
was attenuated by passage and different
host and we talk about vaccines we'll
talk about how that works and there's
just one component in this vaccine so
these are orally administered so I have
the cute little teaspoons here I guess
you drink it
multiplies in your intestinal tract and
affords protection so these are very
effective about 80% protection against
disease now last two years ago when you
know last year when this course was
going on a paper came out someone had
taken these two vaccines and they
sequenced it and they found a
contaminant another virus that wasn't
supposed to be there was a porcine surco
virus so both of these were immediately
withdrawn from the market for about two
months until was decided that this
circle virus wasn't a problem but the
circle virus came from the trypsin that
is used to split the cells that are used
to grow the virus vaccine so if you've
ever done cell culture you know you grow
cells and dishes you split them with
trypsin the trypsin comes from pig
pancreas and the pigs have circle
viruses so that's where the virus came
from all right the last one we'll talk
about is West Nile virus
this one is a Flavie virus isolated in
1937 from the West Nile district of
Uganda so many people when they hear
about West Nile they think they think it
came from Egypt but it didn't came from
Uganda Flavie viruses are envelope
positive strand RNA viruses
19:37 not present in the western
hemisphere until 1999 and that year it
arrived in New York City anybody
remember that he came to New York State
it was an outbreak in Queens and it just
spread all over the u.s. somehow it got
into the u.s. that summer it may have
been imported from Israel as one of the
theories because the sequence of this
virus that came to New York is exactly
the same as an isolate from a goose farm
in Israel so somehow it got over here
and it spread all over the US Canada
Mexico this virus is quite has a quite
large host range it infects hundreds of
different birds mosquitoes and 18 other
vertebrates in addition the virus is an
envelope virus it has a core though that
has icosahedral symmetry and the
symmetry of the core is passed on to the
envelope glycoproteins so if you look at
this envelope virus it structurally has
the glycoproteins have icosahedral
symmetry because of the underlying core
and here's an electron micrograph of the
virus transmission cycle mainly involves
mosquitoes the mosquitoes transmit the
virus back and forth to birds of
different species so the mosquito bites
a bird picks up virus infects another
bird and so forth there are dead end
hosts such as horses and humans so we
get infected by the mosquitoes but we
don't transmit it to there's no evidence
at least that we are transmitting it to
any other host so in nature this exists
in the transmission cycle between birds
and mosquitoes dead end hosts are horses
and humans so it's transmitted to us by
a mosquito bite the incubation period is
3 to 14 days about 20 to 30% of infected
people to develop a flu-like illness
it's called West Nile fever and 80% of
those in fact that have no symptoms at
all so a lot of people can be infected
but this is not a consequence for
spreading the virus to others because we
don't spread it to other people one in
1500 and five
50 people develop neuro invasive disease
the virus gets into your CNS you have
headache ocular manifestations muscle
weakness cognitive impairment some
Placid paralysis and this is associated
with 10% mortality but more importantly
over half of these individuals that have
newer invasive disease have long-term
neurological sequelae very much like the
kids infected with measles where it gets
into the brain so again not a good thing
to have virus in your brain if you
remember we talked about how the innate
response allows West Nile to get into
your brain the TNF produced makes the
capillaries porous so the virus can get
in yes that's that's a bit controversial
probably grooming or mating or something
like that yeah so the here's a little
scheme of pathogenesis the virus is
taken from birds the virus bites us
remember when a mosquito bites you it
deposits the virus below the outer layer
of skin and interestingly what happens
when the virus gets there starts to
multiply and what comes in dendritic
cells right because they sense the
infection virus infects those dendritic
cells very smart and then the dendritic
cells go to the lymph node and then the
virus gets released and they infect
other cells in the lymph nodes so
they've had a perfect ride to where they
like to replicate and from the lymph
node they get into the blood they infect
other organs like the spleen and as we
said earlier tnf-alpha plays a role
getting the virus across the blood-brain
barrier where it replicates in neurons
and that's a cause of the neurological
symptoms in the CNS of most individuals
interferon chemokines and a variety of
t-cells keep the infection in check but
for some reason in certain individuals
they don't work properly and you have
replication in neurons and the these
sequelae so this is the graph of West
Nile in the USA from 1999 to 2008 the
bars are total cases and the open bars
are the cns involvements neuro
invasiveness so you see just thousands
of cases a year four thousand in 2002 a
very high year in 2003 ten thousand this
has to do with climate largely because
when it's very dry
the mosquitoes prefer to bite humans
rather than birds and Dixon de Paume EA
will tell you all about this on the
second to the last lecture of this
course and you can see different numbers
here in subsequent years if you'd like
to know which state the virus can be
found in its basically everywhere
although some states have more than
others 2008 on top here you can see low
numbers for most states but California
had quite a few cases 445 2007 overall
more numbers throughout but every state
essentially having infections how do you
prevent the West Nile at the moment
there are a couple of vaccines and
development because it does cause
significant disease in people where the
virus goes into their brain so there are
three or four different candidates and I
suspect in the next five or ten years
those will be licensed I don't know who
will receive them I suppose it will be a
voluntary vaccine you can you decide for
yourself if you're worried about West
Nile you can get it in any state as you
can see even in New York State but 46
cases in 2008 22 and 2007 the risk is is
rather low so I guess if you move to
California you should probably get the
vaccine when it becomes available for
now the prevention involves mosquito
control you know eliminating standing
water it doesn't long does a lot to
getting rid of the vector that spreads
West Nile so there are many many things
you can do and again Dixon de Paume II
will tell you about this when he talks
about West Nile okay
you